[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ses idées qui gouvernent
le monde nous allons vous parler de
l'ukraine l'ukraine l'éveil d'une nation
après deux années de crise sanitaire le
ciel européen s'est assombri et les
étoiles du monde ont pâli du fait de la
décision brutale et néo impériale de
vladimir poutine d'envahir l'ukraine un
territoire déjà morcelée au sud-est par
l'occupation du donbass et de la
péninsule de crimée
subitement de l'ensemble des frontières
terrestres et maritimes de l'ukraine
l'infanterie la marine et l'aviation
russe en entrée en action bombardant
infrastructures civiles et militaires et
causant des milliers de victimes
innocentes et un exode de plusieurs
millions d'ukrainiens seulement la bonne
surprise venant d'ukraine ce qui devait
être une guerre éclair s'est transformé
en enlisement de la soldatesque rusques
piétinant aux portes des principales
métropoles ukrainienne est aussi et
surtout la nation ukrainienne s'est
dressé avec l'énergie folle de
l'espérance et la résistance de son
peuple conduite par un homme
exceptionnel
volodymyr et lens qui ce conflit russo
écru craignant va interpeller l'europe
et le monde sur la place des petites
nations sur la continuité néo impériale
de la russie sur la défense de
l'occident et sur la menace nucléaire
bref un retour de la terreur que nous
allons chercher à comprendre avec mes
invités que je vous présente irina
dmitri chine vous êtes chercheuse à
l'inalco
vladimir berelowitsch vous êtes
historien à l'école des hautes études en
sciences sociales
emmanuel de waresquiel vous êtes
historien christian saint-etienne
professeur au cnam
le conservatoire national des arts et
métiers
[Musique]
l'ukraine a toujours aspiré à être libre
voyez voltaire déjà le disais est ce que
c'est pertinent est ce que c'est vrai
qu'est ce que vous en pensez irina
dmitri chine ces citations qui vient de
l'histoire de charles xii est
parfaitement vrai l'actualité nous le
montre de manière éclatante nous sommes
au xviiie siècle la moscovie est un état
qui émerge à peine et les grands états
de l'époque s'appelle la suède l'a la
pologne lituanie et la porte ottomane et
le cren il se trouve été un allié ou un
adversaire de ces trois pays et donc la
citation de voltaire était vrai à
l'époque et les parfaitement opérante
aujourd'hui l'habit mire berelowitsch
vous adhérez à cette chose là que
l'ukraine a toujours aspiré oui
certainement je dirais que c'est resté
comme un des points principaux de la
mémoire nationale ukrainienne c'est à
dire que aux origines on parle des
cosaques de est mana qui a émergé au
milieu du xviie siècle et qui était qui
s'est constitué comme une entité
politique indépendante tout en étant
obligés de s'allier tantôt aux russes
tantôt polonais tantôt doctement tantôt
tatane et les tout premiers historiens
notamment
kostomarov par exemple qui n'est pas le
premier a dit que les deux traits
fondamentaux de l'identité nationale
ukrainienne eh bien c'est la liberté et
la démocratie l'égalité c'est ces deux
points principaux alors il est très
frappant que ça perdure aujourd'hui à la
fois dans les esprits dans les faits
manuel de ice qu'elle s'est c'est
difficile à comprendre pour nous l'état
précède la nation en france la
particularité de l'ukraine mon avis
c'est que la nation le sentiment
national précède de très très loin les
temps l'ukraine ce sont des états
différents pendant très longtemps le
crès une partie de l'ukraine qui
s'appelle la galicie avec le vivent qui
s'appelait lembergs comme capital
appartient entre 1772 est quasiment la
première guerre mondiale à laon pire
d'autriche devenu autriche hongrie une
partie une autre partie de l'ukraine a
longtemps été sous la domination
ottomane puis de vie devient reçu
catherine 2 qui met la main sur la
crimée en 1784 donc ce sont des états
mais ça n'empêche ça n'a jamais empêché
le développement d'un sentiment national
qui à mon avis double d'ailleurs
il il prend racine à la fois dans la
paysannerie rue terrienne rite rutten
yen qui est qui et la paysanne la
paysannerie ukrainienne est également
dans les exploits et les combats des
cosaques sa parole comme vous l'avez dit
parfois tenté mais par apollinaire
parfois contre les les ottomans et
contre les russes et contre les polonais
mais il y a un certain nombre de
décrivent un ethnologue
ukrainien je pense à vladimir antonovich
par exemple qui
qui ont qui écrivait qui publient des
livres extrêmement important de défense
du sentiment national notamment de
défense des paysans régnant à l'ouest de
l'ukraine contre la noblesse polonaise
sur ces principes de liberté
qui sont évidemment hostile au servage
russe et qui défendent ces libertés
paysanne ukrainien donc ça c'est lady le
19e et puis il ya eu aussi une tradition
il me semble j'avais j'avais vu ça à
travers les travaux que j'avais mené sur
le duc de richelieu qui a été gouverneur
général de la nouvelle russie au début
du 19e siècle il y assez zahed un peu
comme le dos et h2k d'arrêt pour le pour
l'albanie ces aides les codes-barres je
crois c'est bizarre comme arcop ces
aides ukrainien qui diffuse
l'épopée ukrainienne à travers l'épopée
des cosaques et aussi des tatars nogaye
des galets fussent cette épopée au 19e
siècle ce sentiment national il existe
on parle mais l'état ukrainien ne va pas
reparler dans le détail mais entre le
passé le présent creissan saint-etienne
d'où vient le fait qu' on dit très
souvent aujourd'hui que l'ukraine est le
berceau politique de la russie est ce
que c'est de la simple propagande
pense qu'à deux grandes périodes de
du sentiment national ukrainien qui
n'était pas d'ailleurs le sentiment
national et chrétiens d'aujourd'hui il
ya la période de la de larousse
d'ukraine de ce point de vue c'est vrai
que c'est le redémarrage de la russie
après les périodes sous le joug gains
des tatars mais je pense que le il ya un
deuxième moment qui est plus récent
qui se construit commence à se
construire doucement pendant la période
tsariste mais qui se durcit son pli
fille souterrainement dans la période
soviétique et les ukrainiens ont quand
même été très très très malmené par les
soviétiques et donc qu'ils n'ont pas
tenu leur parole non plus bien on se
souvient qu'ils ont abandonné toutes
leurs armes nucléaires en contrepartie
d'une assurance de faire de la russie
qu'elle les protègeraient et c'est la
russie qui les écrase donc je pense
qu'il ya dans cette deuxième partie lab
la première à le premier sentiment
national ils craignent un c'était un
sentiment d'expansion là je pense qu'il
ya une partie de ressentiment et
l'erreur que fait poutine aujourd'hui on
va en parler l'erreur de poutine à mon
avis va laisser des traces pendant des
décennies mule mais si je n'empêche pas
que les russes ont considéré longtemps
avant même ce conflit que l'ukraine
était un berceau politique qu'est ce que
vous en pensez et rina alors je pense
que nous pouvons en parler
le premier état des slaves orientaux qui
s'appelle la rousse de kate le russe de
kiev ruthénie était tout simplement la
plus vaste état dans cette partie de
l'europe à l'époque un état très
apprécié et dont l'alliance a été
recherché puisque c'est de là que
viennent de kiev donc les pousses de riz
premier dont les autres sortes et rnd
hongrie ou ou de ou de norvège c'était à
la et considérez donc son héritage peut
être revendiquée par les trois peuples
aussi bien par les ukrainiens que par
les russes que par le biélorusse donc la
captation qui a été faite au profit de
la russie exclusive a été élaborée plus
tôt au 19e siècle lorsque la russie
élabore son récit national mais le cren
ne renonce pas du tout à cet héritage
delà de la route de calibre je rappelle
que moscou a été fondée par un prince de
quévillon youri le blard ou le bras long
qui est allé à qui est elle est là bas
et qui a fondé 7,7 moscovie qui après
l'affaiblissement du jour mongole va
progressivement prendre prendre les
sorts et donc au fil des ans on prendre
le contrôle d'une partie de l'ukraine en
élaborant ensuite son récit national
quand même à partir de keyyo alors on
est constamment avec l'ukraine dans le
passé présent on fait des allers-retours
l'a dit me hébert eloids l'invasion de
l'ukraine par l'armée russe a déclenché
une résistance inattendue une résistance
héroïque du peuple ukrainien un art est
enceinte en parlant de ses cette
résistance parler du trésor caché de la
résistance à votre avis c'est quoi ce
trésor caché qui fait que l'ukraine
c'est résister avec cette force
inattendue
me semble que en effet c'était moi je
pense que même pour les gens peut-être
même les mieux informés et les plus
favorables à l'ukraine la force de cette
résistance a été
je crois un objet de surprise pour tout
le monde mais surtout pour ceux qui
pensaient qu'il n'y aurait pas de
sentiment national ukrainien et que
l'ukraine était une création
artificielle que c'était le discours de
poutine je rappelle création en somme de
lénine et de staline et de khrouchtchev
il vient donc on peut s'interroger
finalement alors on peut dire quand même
que jusqu'à la révolution russe et la
guerre civile qui a suivi et y compris
aussi à la collectivisation des terres
sous staline en 29 30 et à la famine qui
a suivi les dires les dossards et ceux
qui les ont suivis connaissait très bien
la force ce sentiment et de ses dangers
pour eux il ya aucun doute là dessus le
matraquage donc le
la culture ukrainienne a fait l'objet
par exemple sous nicolas 1er c'était
plus important
c'était une répression beaucoup plus
importante que pour d'autres régions y
compris des régions nationale avec des
cultures différentes
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé dans la
période soviétique pour qu'on croie que
le nationalisme ukrainien n'existait
plus bien c'est je crois c'est un état
qu'il faut appeler totalitaire
en tout cas sous lénine staline et post
totalitaire peut-être pour ce qui a
suivi et on a tout le monde a cru à une
sorte de pacs soviétique à où les
nations n'existait plus donc ce qu'on
peut dire de l'ukraine était valable
aussi des autres et qu'est ce qui s'est
passé mais en réalité c'est que toute
cette machine qui était d'abord une
machine à écraser sur pendant la guerre
civile d'abord entre 18 et 21 et ensuite
pendant la collectivisation sans aucun
doute puisque quatre millions de morts
quelque chose comme cela dans la zone
ukrainienne et bien pendant toute cette
période là il ya eu à la fois
l'écrasement le nivellement
l'uniformisation et en même temps
conservation des nations et ça je
voudrais insister là dessus on s'en est
aperçu après
le fait que l'intégrale est facteur
d'intégration qui jouait malgré tout un
certain niveau sous l'ancien régime ont
beaucoup notamment économiques ont
beaucoup moins joué dans la période
soviétique et que le fait que
formellement c'était une union des
républiques ce que personne ne prenait
au sérieux s'est avéré en fait très
sérieux et que la langue ukrainienne
rester elle était encore parlé elle est
encore par un élément de résistance
alors sur cette résistance les manuels
de varès qu'elle puisqu'on est dans les
comparaisons est ce que vous diriez que
c'est un moment turc chilien le fait que
henin ce qu'ils se soient levés en
quelque sorte et entraîné son peuple
est-ce que la comparaison fait sens je
suis je suis peu
peu à même de pouvoir vous répondre sur
des questions contemporaines s'agissant
des graines jamais travaillé sur
l'ukraine contemporaine
j'en ai une
modeste connaissance aux 18e et 19e j'ai
envie de rebondir sur ce que dit
vladimir bellevue l'ukraine et qui est
une terre je dirais médiane
tampon entre l'occident et l'orient
c'est tu sais c'est une terre de grands
déplacements c'est une terre martyrs et
l épreuve en martyrs et à l'époque
soviétique et avant à l'époque tsariste
précisément à cause de ce sentiment
national qui a traversé
les époques et qui probablement s'est
renforcée alors qu'ils qui surgit et que
l'on voit apparaître au moment des
grandes crises comme par exemple par
exemple en 1917 à la faveur de la paix
séparée des bolchéviques après la
révolution de février 17,1 moscou et à
saint pétersbourg
on voit apparaître deux républiques
ukrainienne une à lvov à lviv et l'autre
à kiev une république chrétienne
occidentale est une république populaire
d'ukraine qui qui publie une
constitution d'ailleurs qui s'allient en
1918 qui va durer deux ou trois ans qui
va s'effondrer sous le choc des
bolcheviques en 1918 qui publie une
constitution qui est une constitution à
la fois socialiste libéral et anti
bolchévique et on retrouvera ce
sentiment national après 45 avec une
résistance ukrainienne qui va combattre
contre les soviétiques pendant des
années entre 45 et 48 49 je crois et ce
qui conforte encore ce sentiment
national qui devient à 100 qui devient
un étang cette transformation du
sentiment national en état ses 91 92
et c'est probablement et c'est tout à la
gloire de la démocratie et des libertés
a porté par un régime on peut considérer
que il était plein de défauts ce régime
démocratique ukrainien de 91 92 mais en
réalité pendant 20 ans les ukrainiens
ont goûté à ce régime et ce régime cette
démocratie ukrainienne a certainement
renforcé profondément le sentiment
national ukrainien d'où cette résistance
à la russie poutinienne à poutine que
l'on que l'on que l'on constate
aujourd'hui alors cette résistance
poutinienne ce patriotisme ukrainien
christian saint-etienne
est-ce qu'on peut le comparer à des
situations comme parlé d'un moment
church chiliens ont parlé d'où vient
pour vous ce patriotisme ukrainien qui
s'est levée en masse
et notre notablement du fait que ces
deux pays l'ukraine et la russie jusque
là avait des intérêts communs sur le
plan économique sur le plan culturel etc
c'était pas de donation complètement
séparée pense qu'il ya deux éléments
géostratégique il faut introduire
d'abord le premier c'est le traitement
spécial que
l' empire tsariste et puis les
soviétiques ont donné à l'ukraine que
vous avez rappelé sous forme d'une
oppression spécifiques c'était dû au
fait que l'empiré russe et même l'empiré
soviétique ou toujours considéré que son
l'ukraine c'était un élément de perte de
puissance insupportable c'est d'ailleurs
la raison pour laquelle poutine ne
supportait pas le deuxième élément
stratégique qui doit être pris en compte
c'est que alors on se souvient que
kissinger et bray jeans qui avait
parfaitement identifié l'importance de
l'ukraine pour la russie les deux
d'ailleurs disait il faut pas jouer avec
ça il faut tout faire pour séparer
l'ukraine de la russie n'est pas allée
jusqu'au point où on prend l'ukraine
dans l'otan parce que les russes ne
supporteront pas donc dans ce contexte
un des éléments de cette résistance
extraordinaire il faut pas l'oublier
c'est la politique américaine depuis
2014 depuis 2014 les américains ont
investi massivement sur le plan
militaire en termes de conseillers
militaires et de et de matériel en
ukraine ce qui a augmenté lire de
poutine contre l'ukraine et contre les
états unis et de fait l'armée
ukrainienne était beaucoup mieux armés
elle avait fait un effort de formation
considérable de ses soldats est un des
éléments de surprise c'est bien sûr la
résistance sûr lié au fait nationale
mais l'autre élément d'après les
spécialistes militaires qu'on peut
consulter
c'est que les soldats ukrainiens sont
mieux formés individuellement que les
soldats russes et ça c'est quand même
une surprise
sur le plan stratégique au plan
international parce que tout le monde
pensait que les soldats russes surtout
après ce qui s'était passé en syrie
étaient des surhommes et tout à coup on
voit des gamins de 20 ans qui pleure à
la télé pour retourner à la maison donc
ils sont pas tous comme ça mais il y en
avait un certain nombre et envoie des
soldats ukrainien bien armés très
déterminé donc je pense que il faut pas
une un des éléments alors vous posez la
question de dans uncharted
zlin ce qui surprend
c'est complexe parce qu'on est dans un
moment d'admiration pour l'homme
il ya peut-être des éléments à prendre
en compte est-ce qu'il va pas trop loin
sur certains thèmes mais passons mais je
pense qu'il a considérés au moment du
début de la résistance ukrainienne qu'il
allait bénéficier d'une sorte de
parapluie américain un contenu de tous
les investissements militaires que les
états unis avaient fait depuis 2014 et
ça ça a pu
contribuer à l'accent churchill liens
qu'il a pu avoir au départ mais alors
irina dmitri chine
christian saint-etienne vient d'évoquer
le fait que kiss in guerre et brzezinski
de grands hommes politiques america
halle n'a été secrétaire d'état l'autre
a conseillé le président carter ils ont
tous les deux considéré que si on sépare
et l'ukraine de la russie ont porté
atteinte à la dimension impériale de la
russie qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
munster d'abord qu'il faut peut-être
demandé aussi aux ukrainiens ce qu'ils
veulent et je voudrais qu'on pense aussi
que si effectivement les américains
peut-être sont venus en 2014 c'est un
réaction à la l'attaquent de la russie à
l'annexion de la sauver et à la
gastronomie de 14 c'est la descente de
la ghriba qu'un verre oui les choses ne
sont pas de débarquer comme ça c'est ils
sont ils sont venus parce que les russes
avaient déjà attaqué ensuite la demande
du craignent n de rejoindre l'union
européenne
on va rentrer dans le détail voilà mais
sur cette dimension impérial que sans le
lien entre ukraine russie la russie n'a
plus de politique impériale qu'est ce
que vous en pensez la russie est un
empire et c'est qu'on soit content elle
elle a été construite comme tel je
rappellerai oeuvre avant car pauvre
saint ursanne n'empêche que le
simplement
et en 91 lorsque l'union soviétique
s'effondre les pays comme l'ukraine
se mettent à construire leur état nation
les pays comme la russie rumine les
chais qui pensent que les a privés de
quelque chose qu'on leur a enlevé les
territoires au kazakhstan ou ailleurs et
et c'est là où il aurait fallu aider les
russes à construire leur étalement dans
l'oubli à dorment dans les sur cette
question impérial vladimir berelowitsch
d'où ça vient mais brièvement parce
qu'on a beaucoup de questions a pas si
vous voulez c'est comme le bras qui a
été coupée et qu'on sent toujours cette
dimension impérial empirus est finie
veut dire évidemment on peut imaginer
qu'ils sont à reconstruire mais ça me
paraît extrêmement improbable parce
que'il est tout à fait frappant que tous
les discours actuels de nostalgie sont
caricaturaux complètement caricaturaux
ce sont des gens qui se piquent
d'histoire et qui arrachent des petits
bouts d'histoires qui nourrit aucun
rapport ni avec la réalité historique ni
avec la réalité présent il faudrait
encore démontré que l'invasion de
l'ukraine obéit à des motifs de
puissance il ya peut-être un autre motif
bien plus puissant puisqu'il faut penser
à cette date de 2014
c'est la question de la révolution et de
l'euro maidan
le pouvoir russe de peau de poutine a
une peur et ça on le sait des manic des
révolutions de couleur pour lui ce sont
des révolutions manipuler de l'étranger
et qui met en danger tout
l'environnement russe donc la russie
aussi
[Musique]
on est de voir la citation de milan
kundera qui dit qu'aucune nation ne vie
sur la planète terre depuis la nuit des
temps la notion de nation et moderne
êtes vous d'accord pour considérer que
l'idée de nation est tout à fait
contemporaine et que c'est le cas
emmanuel de waresquiel vous vous disiez
que c'est l inverse que c'est d'abord la
nation qui à l'état qu'est venue après
alors comment vous l'état vient avant la
nation vient punch river dans le siège
avant la révolution mais également la
révolution la saynète redit en 1789 je
pense que le l'histoire de l'ukraine
c'est exactement l'inversé pour revenir
à l'obsession russe
[Musique]
impérialiste ou impériale russe moi j'ai
été frappé mais ça tout le monde le sait
du fait que poutine supprime
l'association mémorial je pense que 1
des graves problèmes en russie c'est que
ce travail de mémoire sur la période
communiste bolchévique n'a jamais été
effectuée et donc on saute à pieds
joints dans l' empire tsariste et et on
continue à nourrir cette espèce de rêve
cette nostalgie impériale qui passe
aussi par des considérations économiques
parce que je pense qu'il faut pas faire
l'abstraction de l'obsession russe de la
mer noire des débouchés économiques par
la mer noire ça a était l'obsession de
catherine 2 les trois guerres russo
turque en même du xviiie et du début du
19e siècle sont des guerres pour la
conquête de l'est pour la conquête des
côtes nord de la mer noire qui offre un
nouveau débouché à la russie via les
détroits et la méditerranée et
n'oublions pas que des saints a été dès
le gouvernorat de du duc de richelieu
qui est une ville française je fais une
toute petite parenthèse parce que
personne n'en parle jamais pour
expliquer quand même que odessa a été
fondée par des français
que la colonie la colonie française via
les migrations nobiliaire de la
révolution française était très
importante que le premier gouverneur
civil et militaire d'odessa du centre au
puits de la nouvelle russie qui est tout
tous ces territoires qui vont du nieste
rejusco coupant à l'est de la mer d'azov
qui est immense et deux tiers de la
france du point de vue géographique est
gouvernée par un français par le duc de
richelieu qui construit au dessin sur un
plan clair néoclassique idéal en damier
avec un cadeau un dq planus tous les
grands monuments publics de dessins ont
été construits par des architectes
néoclassique français tomates au monde
challes et d'autres qui ont
véritablement créé au dessin quand l
origine ou y arrivant en 1800 il ya deux
mille habitants et quand ils quittent au
descendu 114 pour confier au dessin
d'ailleurs à un autre français qui
s'appelle langeron il ya cinquante mille
habitants et c'est la particularité de
dessins qui est une ville même sous
l'empiré tsariste libéral avec des races
très mélangé on appelait ça la nation
levantine du fait de la mer noire de la
méditerranée des grecs des bulgares des
turcs des italiens des marseillais et le
commerce pardeza notamment le commerce
du blé a été essentielle à la survie de
la france est vraiment
intéressant oui c'est intéressant mais
c'est la statue domine engendrait mais
je voudrais escaliers potemkine je
voudrais revenir sur la question de la
nation qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce
que dit kundera quand il dit que les
nations
d'europe centrale et orientale ont été
coincés d'un côté par la russie de
l'autre côté par l'allemagne alors que l
avait une véritable scène nationale
qu'est ce que vous en pensez il faut pas
comparer le cren à à la france le crâne
atteint pour parler d europe centrale et
orientale a été privé d'état
dans l'époque moderne donc il faut
comparer le cren au petit peuple comme
les appelle d'europe centrale qui vivent
sous une domination d'une part la
domination russe d'autre part la
donation austro hongroise et tout au
long 19e siècle ces peuples sans état
développent leur sentiment national
d'abord sur le même chemin et les
tchèques et les ukrainiens d'abord
l'intérêt pour le folklore la
constatation de cette différence entre
leurs peuples et les centres qui les
domine l'étude du folklore son
classement le développement dans la
littérature dans tout ce qui se
développe sans étape par les
enthousiastes et qui ensuite vers la fin
du 19e siècle va servir de prodromes
pour les revendications politiques donc
toute nation ukrainienne est construite
d'abord autour des champs autour des
comme ça autour des poètes comme comme
shevchenko autour des des historiens
vous avez évoqué antonovich piété du
courant socialiste
ukrainien mais il y avait aussi et c'est
à cette époque là qu'apparaît notre
niche les qui aimera le coup chef qui
est qui écrit l'histoire ukrainienne à
partir de la route de quais par l'état
kazakh au xviiie siècle et ensuite donc
le set ce sentiment va se matérialiser
au xviie siècle au moment de
l'effondrement de l'empiré la fin de la
première guerre mondiale et en ukraine
apparaît la république populaire
d'ukraine
fondée par les par les hommes politiques
de courants socialistes qui pense
d'abord pouvoir pouvoir avoir une
autonomie au sein de la russie et qui
ensuite finissent par proclamer
l'indépendance ukrainienne qui a connu
plusieurs arrêts vous diriez vous diriez
que ces petites nations qui sont de
maintenant des grandes nations
n'ont rien à voir avec la russie
alors la russie était la puissance
dominante on a on a eu une histoire
commune dans le sens où hulk rennes la
majeure partie de l'ukraine faisait
partie de l'empiré russe donc forcément
ses 300 ans était une vie commune
seulement du côté russe on développe la
notion de peuple frère du côté ukrainien
on estime que dépit le xviiie siècle et
la bataille de poltava que mazeppa avec
charles xii maire de contre pierre
premier que l'ukraine
commence une histoire de luttes de
résistance à l'égard à l'égard de la
russie après c'est beaucoup plus subtil
il ya eu quand même une absorption des
élites ukrainienne qui au xviiie siècle
se sont parfaitement intégrés dans la
noblesse russe et ont servi lempire
l'empiré russe le peuple finit par être
le seul gardien de cette identité
ukrainienne qui est repris à la fin du
19e siècle par les lettrés par les
universitaires à vous écouter on a des
allers-retours permanents entre le passé
et le présent
à propos de cette guerre en ukraine
alors puisqu'on fait des allers-retours
et qu'on considère que la russie
d'aujourd'hui est finalement dans la
continuité de la russie tsariste de la
russie bolchévique christian
saint-etienne est ce que vous diriez que
ce qui s'est passé en 32 33 ce fameux
holodomor c'est à dire cette famine
imposé à la population ukrainienne
vient en anticipation de ce qui s'est
passé avec le massacre de boudhha où on
a parlé d'un crime contre l'humanité est
ce que tout ça est dans une continuité
non feinte parce que c'est intéressant
de droit sessegnon mais c'est
intéressant de voir si la continuité
guerrière est une continuité barbare
pour dire qu'il ya 2 continue t il ya
une continuité de violence russe
partout où ils sont puisque finalement
ça rappelle beaucoup ce qui s'est passé
à alep
donc il ya une sorte de violence
guerrière qui s'affiche et s'affirme par
tous les russes mènent la guerre de
façon extrêmement barbares en ayant
quasiment
[Musique]
codifié
le fait qu' on fasse peur en écrase la
population civile pour casser le moral
des combattants donc c'est une tradition
russe mais pour
l'autre élément de continuité c'est que
c'est cette méfiance dont vous parliez
tout à l'heure vis-à-vis de la puissance
potentielle de l'ukraine en fait parce
que l'ukraine est extrêmement riche en
réalité c'est la partie potentiellement
la plus riche du grand empire russe
c'est c'est la partie c'est la partie
sur le plan agricole avec des rendements
fenomeno les fameuses terres noires donc
mais ensuite tout le secteur minier donc
la continuité de cette vision de russes
qui maintient toujours le couvercle sur
l'ukraine celle-là on la retrouve
spécifiquement en 31 32 il ya vraiment
une volonté de casser le peuple de 2,2
de le faire crever en physiquement en
lui enlevant le pain de la bouche il ya
un film extraordinaire d'un journaliste
anglais qui est allée qui est sorti il
ya deux ans voilà les garennes jones
gallois voilà est qui et qui montre la
réalité delà de cet épisode et donc ils
avaient une double continuté la violence
de l'armée russe partout et d epuis la
volonté du pouvoir politique russe de
toujours cassé et maintenir sous terre
la puissance potentielle de l'ukraine
est ce que vous diriez vladimir guerrero
beach holodomor 32-33 boudhha 2022
ya un fil continu de d'une forme de
violence la violence et dans ce régime
c'est à dire mais il est difficile de
comparer sinon encore une fois sous une
forme quasi caricaturale la russie de
poutine d'aujourd'hui et celle de
staline et la réalité n'est pas la même
là il s'agit de casser une paysannerie
et ça il ya une discussion pour savoir
dans quelle mesure cette famille n'a été
provoqué ce qui est hors de doute
complètement hors de doute ce qu'elle a
été utilisée par staline pas forcément
seulement contre les ukrainiens mais
principalement contre les ukrainiens
c'est à dire la paysannerie ukrainienne
il s'agit pas ici de nation encore calé
derrière quelque part mais il s'agit
surtout d'une rébellion qui était en
train de ses 30 dans les campagnes
ukrainienne et qui allait embraser
l'ensemble de ses campagnes alors là on
ne sait pas du tout où ça serait arrivé
si si si on arrête à 1000 euros là et
donc il a profité de cette famine pour
casser cet élan révolutionnaire peut-on
dire parce que c'était de guerre
paysanne qui avait commencé peut-être au
début du siècle en 1904 1905 et qui est
entrèrent en train de continuer surtout
après le période de l'anep pendant la
collectivisation donc c'est là là
effectivement on peut dire qu'à une
continuité mais comme vous disiez c'est
une continuité dans la barbarie et la
brutalité et manager je voudrais car à
la famine de 32 succès des grandes
purges staliniennes de 36 et 37 qui vise
cette fois les élites ukrainienne et qui
sont eblé également je pense qu'il ya
tout de même provenant des différences
du point de vue la violence entre ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui et ce qui s'est
passé à l'époque de staline mais il
reste preumont une continuité de haine
vis-à-vis de l'identité chrétienne d'un
côté renforcé par la haine de la
démocratie que probablement porte
poutine
cette démocratie qui n'est en 91 et qui
ne fait que se développer depuis depuis
20 ans est ce que veut dire diriez
puisque le débat est posé que cette
guerre en ukraine pose la question d'un
crime contre l'humanité d'une guerre
génocidaire
os qu'on emploie des grands mots à ce
sujet là qui veut répondre là j'aimerais
dire à tout de même paradoxe de
l'histoire et facéties de l'histoire que
l'homme qui a inventé raphael lemkin
l'homme qui a inventé
le concept de génocide en 1943 aux états
unis et qui va l'imposer à à
l'organisation des nations unies je
crois en 1948 est né à lviv qui
s'appelait à l'époque lembergs qui était
sous domination polonaise
c'est un juif qui se réfugient qui
échappe aux massacres qui se réfugie aux
états unis et je suggère à nos
téléspectateurs la lecture de ce livre
remarquable
à l'est mais retour à lembach est un
magnifique livre qui
est ce que l'absence et pour parler
d'aujourd'hui je sais que vous répugne à
le faire emmanuel de waresquiel un peu
mais je suis mytho wayne drake qui en a
qui en acier un historien ne l'a pas
mais on parle de crimes contre
l'humanité on parle de génocide puisque
vous évoquez justement ce les
initiateurs en quelque sorte parce
qu'ils étaient deux avocats je croyais n
1 qui a parlé du crime contre l'humanité
et l'autre du génocide y venez tous les
deux de l'un vers l'autre ne venez pas
de bol ils étaient tous les deux élèves
de l'école de diversité devant leurs
délégués de droit non dans le cas précis
là où nous sommes aujourd'hui ça
ressemble à un crime génocidaire ça
ressemble un crime contre l'humanité et
génocide est une notion juridique donc
je les laisse aux juristes mais si elle
devait être appliquée moi il me semble
tout de même que les la grande famine
plus ou moins provoqué par staline en 32
me paraît pouvoir plus relevé de ceux de
cette notion en tout cas la notion de
crime contre l'humanité que ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui même ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui terrible mais faisons
attention aux mots que nous utilisons
avec la notion de génocide et à peine
prononcée à l'époque de nuremberg des
procès de nuremberg elle apparaît plus
tard comme je le dis en 48 à l'onu donc
faisons attention à ce qu'on dit alors à
ce que celui sur ce point irina sur ce
point donc si on veut revenir à la
famine vous savez que raphael lemkin
dans les 1,50 a
fait un texte qui malheureusement est
restée à l'état débauche où il inclut la
famine ukrainienne sont dans la notion
de génocide donc il parle de génocide
arménien de de la famine et de la choix
donc pour le fondateur de ce principe le
cren était donc ce qui s'est passé en
ukraine relève de génocide parce qu'ils
le considèrent en trois dimensions
d'abord la destruction de l'église
ukrainienne don de l'esprit la
destruction des élites l'ukrainienne du
cerveau en quelque sorte et la
destruction du du corps ukrainien qui
est la paysannerie puisque l'édition
ukrainienne à l'époque était
essentiellement la nation paysanne donc
donc ces trois éléments sont
constructifs pour lui de cette
disparition de cette volonté de faire
disparaître un nation ukrainienne en
parlant d' aujourd'hui effectivement
nous sommes tous d'accord de dire que
c'est une notion juridique et c'est au
tribunal de se prononcer et c'est la
raison pour laquelle les ukrainiens
aujourd'hui dès le premier jour ont mis
en place toute une série de banques est
de commission de juristes français sont
partis en ukraine pour collecter les
faits pour les systématiser et pour
faire immédiatement à chaud tout le
travail qui servira au tribunal de se
prononcer par la suite ce qui est
important de savoir c'est que la
déclaration à la convention sur la
prévention et la répression du crime de
génocide
par de la destruction d'un d'un d'un
groupe en totalité ou en partie et c'est
là dedans que peut jouer
la notion de génocide parce que
lorsqu'on parle des tous les éléments
constitutifs de génocide on parle de la
destruction
de se déplacer les enfants d'un groupe à
un autre le fait d'empêcher les
naissances au sein d'emg ou le fait de
causer des dommages physiques et
mentales irréparable à ou importante en
tout cas une nation donc il ya
aujourd'hui des éléments de deux
génocides qu'on peut constater en
ukraine et la chose essentielle il y à
l'intentionnalité l intentionnalité elle
est présente aussi bien dans les
discours de poutine avant la guerre que
dans les discours postérieur et
notamment celui de alors d'un versement
vladimir berelowitsch les russes et
notamment vladimir poutine ont justifié
cette guerre en disant qu'il s'agissait
de des nazis fier l'ukraine qu'est-ce
qui l'heure n'est en réalité
des nazis en ukraine de ce qu'il en
reste
que vaut cet argument au delà de la
propagande s'il faudrait c'est une
longue saison
difficile résumé essais entendirent
minimum mais qu'ils soient
en rapport avec la réalité oui donc la
difficulté des difficultés ce qui a
jamais eu à proprement parler de nazis
en ukraine même pendant le l'occupation
allemande et l'épisode dendérah dans
deraa a fait de la prison donc est le
paradoxe c'est d'imaginer qu'ils
pouvaient avoir des ukrainiens nazis
alors que les allemands nazis n'aurait
jamais accepté que des ukrainiens soit
nazis ce n'est tout à fait impossible
puisque les ça avait été une race
inférieure ce qui est vrai tout à fait
incontestablement c'est que en 30 ans 40
enfin 41 pardon donc après l'occupation
de la galicie
les allemands étaient accueillis en
libérateurs et qu'il y a eu à ce moment
là une tentative de construire de
nouveaux une entité étatique et
craignait
c'est ben deja n'était pas tout seul
c'était sans doute dans ce set
consommation un des plus sympathiques si
je peux dire à la cause nazie
son idéologie était fasciste ou
fascisante qu'il était incontestablement
antisémites et que pour lui ça pourrait
représenter un idéal mais son grand
idéal en réalité c'est un idéal national
ukrainien ce n'était pas aux rues mais
ce qu'il en reste aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui si vous voulez la question
c'est que en 2014 les russes en
par leurs actions souterraines ont en
quelque sorte de nouveau réunifiée
l'ukraine occidentale et l'ukraine
centrale et orientale et que à l'euro
maidan ont participé toutes sortes de
gens et y compris des groupes qui était
sympathisant qui cultivait la tradition
de bandeira qui était le chemin des
chefs donc pas le seul d'ailleurs de
nationalistes ukrainiens pendant la
guerre voilà alors si il suffit de
comparer les chiffres des élections si
des groupes de ce genre le mouvement le
parti sodas etc ont eu
des aux élections des succès
relativement important pendant la
première période
aujourd'hui c'est à dire à la dernière
élection présidentielle
ce parti a recueilli moins de 2% donc il
ya il est faux de parler d'eux n'est en
réalité celle là
pour cent de gens qui auraient qui
seraient dans cette nostalgie là mais
c'est même pas la nostalgie du nazisme
c'est la nostalgie du mouvement national
ukrainien qu'on peut qualifier d'extrême
droite si on veut en tout cas
nationaliste radical voilà c'est ça
c'est ça merci
[Musique]
pour parler
géopolitique aujourd'hui on essaie de
situer ce conflit ukrainien entre
l'occident et l'asie
christian saint-etienne il ya une espèce
de aujourd'hui de démarcation qui est
fait entre l'occident démocratique et
une russie impériale de toujours qu'est
ce que ça vous inspire cette démarcation
il faut traiter avec
quelques précautions
en ukrainien un sentiment national et à
l'ouest de l'ukraine il ya une tradition
européenne très anciennes à l'est du
dniepr on est dans une vision
plus russe mais enfin on est dans un
moment de fascination pour l'ukraine
mais avant la le conflit actuel la
structure sociale de l'ukraine était
aussi pourri que celle de la russie avec
donc on danse plus le dire aujourd'hui
du fait de ce moment chercher liens et
du fait de ce moment de résistance mais
les oligarques ukrainien était au moins
aussi monstrueux que les oligarques
russes puisque ça allait jusqu'à ce que
certains oligarques avaient leurs
propres députés dans le parlement
ukrainien avec des groupes qu'ils
avaient fait élire et qui leur était
officiellement rattaché donc on a une
démocratie qui n'est pas une démocratie
libérale représentative à l'occidentale
avec
les canons qui sont reconnus quand ça
fonctionne comme en angleterre ou à
certaines périodes en france puisque
aujourd'hui même en france c'est un peu
compliqué donc
je pense que c'est ce qui est le plus
remarquable
en ukraine aujourd'hui plus que bien sûr
il ya une volonté de démocratie mais
c'est un c'est ce sentiment libéral
qu'on évoquait tout à l'heure qui est
qui qui est constant dans l'histoire de
l'ukraine cette volonté de de liberté
individuelle
il ne faut pas traduire nécessairement
dans une attente d'un système
démocratique libéral à l'anglais alors à
la lumière de l'histoire emmanuel de
waresquiel est ce que vous diriez que la
russie a toujours cherché à kidnapper
l'occident
certains diplomates français se sont
inquiétés mais curieusement comme talent
rend par exemple qui comparent elle a
réussi à une montagne de neige et qui a
passé sa vie ses 60 ans de pouvoir
communiste a phase est en jeu tous les
régimes à essayer de créer une espèce de
cordon sanitaire par la pologne via la
pologne mais aussi ce qu'il appelait
l'alliance du nord avec le danemark en
1800 contre la russie mais étrangement
d'un point de vue politique diplomatique
et même culturelle je constate tout de
même une fascination française pour la
russie enfin on parlait de voltaire tout
à l'heure mais mon kiki dit qu'il dit
des choses intéressantes sur l'ukraine
mais qui traitait quand même catherine
deux de ses mines de sémiramis du nord
est qui comparaît la russie -où paradis
terrestre et grimm et diderot tout le
monde va se jeter au pied de catherine 2
et ça continue ça traverse tout le 19e
siècle jusqu'à l'alliance russe de
2892 si mes souvenirs sont bons qui nous
conduit tout droit aux tranchées de 1914
et sans parler des voyages
d'intellectuels des compagnons de route
du communisme français en russie jusqu'à
ce que gide s'aperçoivent que il existe
il existe quelques petits problèmes en
russie écrivent retour du rss et et se
fasse traiter de renégats donc c'est une
vieille tradition c'est très étrange
très étrange
il est diplomate les diplomates français
qui ont eu suffisamment qui ont été
suffisamment lucide pour dénoncer ses
ambitions russes vers l'occident ses
ambitions occidentale de la russie sont
assez rares on les compte sur les doigts
d'une main je pense en particulier à
talant que je connais bien mais dans la
tradition diplomatique française ils
sont assez peu nombreux et napoléon
qu'est ce qu'il était comme napoléon
harare les alliances russe et c'est
assez d'ailleurs pour ça que talent
donne sa démission
après le traité de tessit sur le fameux
radeau du même nom en 1807 talent qui
désapprouve absolument l'alliance de la
france avec la russie donne sa démission
du ministère des affaires étrangères et
napoléon a si bien rêver la rue cela
l'alliance russe qu'il a fini par la la
la conquérir ou pas retenter de la
conquérir jusqu'à la bérézina que non
que l'on connaît comment vous passez
cette ligne de démarcation
occident russie vladimir berelowitsch
mais on met ou la russie par rapport à
l'occident
on peut dire je crois si on veut
vraiment considérer la longue période en
tout cas depuis dix ans le xviiie siècle
que la russie avait un pied dans
l'europe et un autre en dehors mais n'a
jamais été entièrement en europe je
crois que c'est évident et pour les
européens malgré tout je dirais aussi
malgré tout malgré ce que vous ce que
vous venez de dire il y avait toujours
une certaine méfiance une certaine
incertain comment dire un capital de
déception par rapport à la russie
étaient trop énormes et trop inquiétante
et même des gens très bien intentionnés
vraiment à la fin du 19ème siècle dans
le cadre de l'alliance franco-russe
comme en face c'était juste avant pardon
mais c'était un atoll leroy-beaulieu par
exemple et bien si vous lisez
attentivement son livre empire des tsars
et des russes vous verrez qu'il voit des
points qui sont très clairement extra
européens et le dit d'ailleurs il le dit
dans sa préface et part d'un pays qui
est entre les deux rives et qu'on pour
lui il était convaincu qu'il allait
arriver à cette autre rive qui est l
europe mais en moments de en 1906 1907
après la première révolution russe il se
force à y croire si on allie si on lit
attentivement ses articles ils doutent
ils doutent très fortement et bien sûr
la suite
s'il avait vécu jusqu'à la période
bolchévique qu'est ce qu'il aurait dit
parce que là la russie selouane
complètement de l'occident et alors est
ce qu'elle a voulu kit d'un ps qu'elle
veut kidnappé lempire d'eads ça on n'a
jamais voulu kidnappé l'occident qu'on
deraa a écrit cela on sait bien de quoi
il parle il parle des nations d'europe
centrale dans la période soviétique où
il ya eu réellement la kidnapping mais
jamais sauf peut-être à certains moments
sous lénine enfin que la guerre russo
polonaises en 20 21 ou également staline
après la deuxième guerre mondiale jamais
le les dirigeants russes n'ont rêvé de
conquérir l'europe mais que actuellement
liait dans la petite cervelle de poutine
pardonnez moi l'expression
et danser dans ses stratégies l'idée de
défaire de l'union européenne de défaire
le temps et de contrôle et l'europe
occidentale ça je crois que ça ne fait
pas l'ombre d'un doute alors irina
dmitri chine à votre avis si on voulait
poser un cordon sanitaire entre
l'occident d'un côté la russie de
l'autre il faudrait pleinement intégré
l'ukraine dans l'union européenne et
l'otan
il faudrait intégrer le nions l ukraine
pleinement à union européenne le temps
mais pas dans le but de créer un cordon
sanitaire je pense que je parle de
cordon sanitaire entre la notion
d'occident et la russie par ailleurs la
russie se considèrent être avoir les
deux les deux pieds aussi bien en
occident kankankan orient je pense que
ce qui est ce qui serait dans l'intérêt
de la russie et de l'ukraine et de
l'europe c'est que la russie guérisse de
la folie dans laquelle elle a été
entraînée par personne dirigeants
actuels et
cela c'est cela qui est qui qui
permettrait aussi bien à l'ukraine que
qu'à l'europe qu'est la russie d'
d'aller de l'avant et de construire un
véritable des relations et des états où
c'est l'homme qui serait au centre des
préoccupations et non les chimères
derrière lequel on court parce que
peut-être le cren n'est pas une
démocratie parfaite mais je rappellerai
qu'elle a quand même fait de révolution
en 2004 à 2010 2014 et à chaque fois
c'était le peuple qui est contre les
élites qui est corrompu ou qu'ils
voulaient l'entraîné loin de l'europe ou
de loin d'eux ses aspirations et ça il
faut il faut les soigner je vous laisse
un mot à chacun des jeux
je pense à ce que disait raymond aron
dans guerre et paix entre les nations
les sorties d'empyr sont toujours des
moments extrêmement difficiles et c'est
ce que vit la russie aujourd'hui et un
contrario peut-être que l'euphorie
occidental qui s'est développée après la
chute du mur de berlin après 1989 n'a
pas suffisamment tenu compte de ses
fragilités russe en allons peut-être un
peu trop loin voilà ce sont les deux les
deux choses que j'aimerais vous vous
dites en un mot emmanuel de waresquiel
c'est la fin de l'empiré russe cette
guerre en ukraine marque la fin de l'an
peru sera très difficile de prédire la
norme est orient mais votre point de vue
c'est celui là on a beau dire des
historiens que ce soit le profil de
bord christian saint-etienne je pense
que ça serait dangereux de vouloir
utiliser l'ukraine contre bouclier comme
bouclier contre la russie je pense qu'on
s'en sortira pas je reviens à ce que
disait kissinger et breizh jeans qui
venons ce qu'on s'en sortira pas si on
n'arrive pas à construire un nouvel
ordre européen dans lequel la russie
trouverait sa place pour ce serait
probablement le meilleur moyen pour
essayer de guérir ses tentations
impérial voir impérialiste et ça
l'un et l'autre a appelé à ce qu'on
fasse ce travail dans les années 90 2000
il n'a pas été fait et on se retrouve
dans une situation aujourd'hui qui est
extrêmement difficile donc
vouloir moi je cautionnerais contre le
fait de faire rentrer l'ukraine dans
l'otan parce que je pense que ça ne fera
qu excité
l'impérialisme russe on obtiendra
l'effet inverse de celui qui est
souhaitable ce qu'il faut c'est intégré
et la russie et d'ukraine dans un nouvel
ordre merci alors le moment est venu
maintenant de vous présenter une
bibliographie
je voudrais signaler le livre de pierre
laurin l'ukraine une histoire entre deux
destins alexandra goujon
l'ukraine de l'indépendance à la guerre
le voyage de monsieur herriot irina
dmitri chine alors là il ya un petit
côté d'humour
dites-nous en deux mots ce que vous avez
voulu montrer dans ce livre bien ce qui
m'intéressait c'est là les raisons
d'abord comprendre s kério a vu quelque
chose quand il est allé en ukraine en 33
at il vu la famille s'il n'a rien s'il a
vu pourquoi et là ils la nier s'il n'a
rien vu pourquoi il n'est rien eu et
donc des sûr c'est une référence au
voyage de monsieur mais c'était un choc
il est publié chez l'harmattan
un ouvrage que j'estime capitale pour
penser la politique aujourd'hui
milan kundera un occident kidnappés ou
la trace de la tragédie de l'europe
centrale c'est publié chez gallimard
emmanuel de waresquiel voyage autour de
mon enfance alors c'est un récit publié
chez tallandier
va pas grand chose à voir avec le sujet
traité
livre qui vient de sortir c'est c'est
pas une biographie
comment vous qualifieriez seule espèce
de promenade poétique autour du monde de
l'enfance de vote renforce oui mais
l'enfoncent à quelque chose d'universel
et vous avec émotion est ce que nabokov
appelle la volupté du souvenir il c'est
un souvenir avec une maison familiale
qui demeure volant voilà un livre donc
qui vient de sortir et que je conseille
à tous nos téléspectateurs vladimir
berelowitsch le grand siècle russe alors
évidemment c'est le siècle de catherine
ii au nom venant 19e siècle c'est le 19e
pourquoi vous n'avez pas pris catherine
d'ajustement et parce que le grand
siècle rue c'est le 19e siècle parce que
c'est là que tout se forme réellement et
bien sûr le xviiie siècle très important
mais si vous voulez les bases de l'enppi
y parlait base mais disons le
fonctionnement de l'enppi c'est vraiment
le 19e siècle d'ailleurs le régime
soviétique par exemple a hérité beaucoup
de choses de cette période là la
littérature russe la culture russe est
le 18ème siècle
incontestablement alors avec vous
christian saint-etienne au zoo l'europe
des nations donc carrément c'est
l'europe des notions et pas l'europe
fédérale c'est bien ça en fait de vous
dans un an deux mots
l'europe avant les événements actuels
mais je pense que il faut les traiter
avec un peu de circonspection parce que
des quelques velléités européenne
actuelle d'actions communes sont
fragiles mais on observe quand même qui
a pas d'europe puissance que l'europe
est ballotté dans le contexte du conflit
entre la chine et les états unis pour la
domination mondiale et donc je propose
de faire un noyau dur de nations
européennes qui prennent en main une
politique stratégique réel parce que on
le voit l'union européenne à 27 c c'est
plus un syndicat qu'une capacité à jour
merci madame ainsi messieurs avoir
participé à cette émission merci à
l'équipe dès le cp et je vous laisse
avec
cette pensée du héros ukrainien
volodimir et l'ins qui nous ne
renoncerons pas nous ne perdrons pas
nous nous battrons être ou ne pas être
nous serons vous voyez qu'il y a de la
culture shakespearienne chez elle
inscrit
[Musique]